the United States has released footage
of a Russian fighter jet colliding with
an American drone the U.S Air Force says
two Russian aircraft conducted an unsafe
and unprofessional intercept of the
unmanned drone in international airspace
over the Black Sea close to Ukraine on
Tuesday the Russian jets are accused of
dumping fuel on the Drone and striking
its propeller causing damage so severe
that its remote pilot was forced to
bring it down
I wear it joined Now by former air Vice
Marshal Sean Bell now as a former pilot
give us your take on what has happened
here it's an amazing bit of footage
isn't it for the 21st century the U.S
claimed that the a couple of Russian
Jets have down one of their 32 million
dollar drones the Russians Delight
denied any involvement but earlier today
the Americans released video footage of
this it's taken a while because they
have to strip it of all of the sensitive
information there's normally loads of
overlays on there but it's pretty clear
what's happened from that video footage
there were two passes by the Russian
aircraft shown here the first one
they're jumping fuel the first one gets
very close to the Drone but actually
seems to miss it and actually not you
can see it's running up the the
propelleries at the rear of the Drone
here and then the second aircraft might
have been the same aircraft or its
wingman has another go at attacking it
this time gets much much closer the
Drone actually impacts
um the the propeller if we look at a
couple of Stills though from this from
this a transaction the first one is it's
just on the attack where the Russian
aircraft is starting to release its some
fuel now normally you have a fuel dump
system if you have an emergency you need
to lower your weight before you land the
aircraft this is not in the Russian
Pilots aren't doing it for that reason
they're trying to use fuel as a weapon
here and they're trying to completely
douse the Drone particularly the engine
at the back with aviation fuel which
will either blow up or cause the engine
to fail and that's why they're trying to
get so close to it if we look at the
second image though close up this is
just before the impact and this is
because the the Drone operates at
relatively slow speeds and it's 200
miles an hour it still sounds fast but
relatively slow and it's very
maneuverable at those speeds most
military jets this jet will operate
normally up to eight times as fast as
that and it's really not comfortable at
those slow speeds it wallows through the
sky and what when you watch the video
through what's happening is they're
trying to get the jet as close as
possible last minute the Russian pilot
readers it realizes the closure rate is
just awful pulls back hard you can see
the curve of this a plume here and
actually just blows it and washes into
the Jet and actually hits the propeller
the propellers on these drones are
really fragile if they're taking out the
Drone goes down almost certainly damage
the Russian aircraft as well but of
course we'll probably not ever hear any
more about that so is this definitely an
accident or incompetence well I think
the first thing is that this happened in
international airspace it shouldn't
actually have happened uh at all
routinely Russian aircraft come and
enter UK airspace we go and intercept
them very professionally but we don't
shoot them down as soon as they come in
almost certainly the Russians were not
planning to shoot down the if they
wanted to do that they'd have used
bullets and just taken it out almost
certainly they were messing around with
it and the Russian incompetence led to
the challenge I think the attention at
the moment will turn to the recovery of
this drone we don't know exactly where
it went down but it was in the Black Sea
probably relatively close to Crimea and
that's the backyard of of the Russians
the Americans be concerned about any
sensitive material uh went on but almost
certainly this incident wasn't a wasn't
a provocation by the way it was almost
certainly an act of incompetence by a
Russian pilot they don't get that much
training they don't get that many hours
the challenge of course with such
tensions in the region these accidents
can have unintended consequences and
really could lead to an escalation in
this conflict yeah incompetence can lead
to that as well as a deliberate action
thank you very much Sean for taking us
through all of that